Francia es el único país que hace que los
argentinos parezcan gente humilde. El ego
de los franceses es tan superlativo, que ni
siquiera cabe dentro de las fronteras del
país. Y eso explica que en el siglo XIX,
Francia se dedicara a colonizar otros países…
Casi la mitad de África fue una colonia francesa
y, de hecho ¿A que no adivináis cuál es
la lengua más hablada en el África subsahariana?
¡Exacto! ¡El francés!
¡Pero no sólo eso! Seguro que todos habréis
oído decir que América Latina es el patio
trasero de Estados Unidos ¿verdad? Pues bien,
África es el patio trasero de Francia.
Por ejemplo, en el año 2011, Francia lideró
todas las operaciones militares contra Gadafi.
Dos años más tarde, el Gobierno de Francois
Hollande envió tropas para defender al presidente
de la República Centroafricana. Al mismo
tiempo, los soldados franceses también estaban
luchando contra los terroristas islámicos
en Mali. Básicamente, el ejército francés
ha estado presente en prácticamente todos
los conflictos armados que se han producido en África.
Para que os hagáis una idea, Francia controla
incluso la divisa que se utiliza en muchos
países africanos. En otras palabras, que
aunque hace décadas que los países africanos
se independizaron, Francia todavía mantiene
una influencia brutal sobre sus gobiernos.
Podéis llamarlo poder blando, diplomacia
o, simplemente, colonialismo 2.0. Y ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando muchos… ¡Seguro
que Francia se está haciendo rica con las
colonias africanas! ¿Verdad? Pues, mis queridos
amigos de VisualPolitik… nada más lejos
de la realidad.
En los últimos 10 años, el comercio de Francia
con África ha bajado de un 10 a un 4,7%
¡Tal cual como lo oís! Aunque Francia domina
la política Africana, la economía es otra
historia totalmente distinta. De hecho, tras
siglos de colonialismo y neocolonialismo,
los países africanos apenas han evolucionado.
Apenas hay empresas nuevas que hayan surgido
gracias a la inversión francesa. Y, mientras
tanto, Francia se gasta miles de millones
de euros todos los años en mantener su cuota
de influencia en el continente, aunque a la
hora de la verdad, apenas consigan sacarla
ningún beneficio.
Y… ¿A que no adivináis quién si está
exprimiendo al máximo la colaboración con
África? ¡Exacto! Estamos hablando de…
Las empresas chinas y Africa se necesitan
el uno al otro más que nunca
Desde los últimos diez años, la inversión
china ha cambiado el skyline de casi todas
las ciudades africanas. Algunos países como
Etiopía se están convirtiendo en potencias
industriales, sobretodo en el sector textil.
Las empresas chinas no sólo están aprovechando
la mano de obra barata sino que, además,
han encontrado un nuevo mercado en el que
vender sus productos ¡Tal cual como lo oís!
Los móviles chinos están arrasando en África
y cada vez más gente está aprendiendo el
idioma de Confucio en lugar del de Moliere.
En otras palabras, que mientras Francia manda
soldados, China manda hombres de negocios.
Y parece que les está funcionando bastante
bien.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Por qué Francia
no ha sabido capitalizar su influencia en
África? ¿Y qué puede hacer el nuevo presidente
francés, Emmanuel Macron, para mejorar esta
situación? Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta
pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
DESVENTAJAS DEL PATERNALISMO
Los que seáis veteranos seguidores de VisualPolitik
ya sabéis tras la II Guerra Mundial, todos
los países africanos se independizan de sus
colonizadores. Pero no os equivoquéis ¡No
todos los colonizadores se comportaron de
la misma forma! Por ejemplo, España tenía
dos colonias en África: Sahara y Guinea Ecuatorial.
Cuando estos dos países quisieron independizarse,
el gobierno de España dijo “¡Anda! ¿Pero
teníamos colonias en África? Pues nada,
oye, si se quieren ir que se vayan, que bastante
tenemos con lo que tenemos por aquí”. Con
Italia pasó algo parecido. Habían invadido
Etiopía durante la época de Mussolini y
tampoco estaban en condiciones de oponer mucha
resistencia a la descolonización. Sin embargo,
el caso de Francia era muy distinto. Por aquella
época, el presidente francés era este señor
que veis en pantalla que se llamaba CHARLES
DE GAULLE. Charles de Gaulle era… ¿Cómo
lo podría definir? Algo así como Donald
Trump pero con cerebro.
“Francia no podría ser Francia sin su grandeza”
--Charles de Gaulle
Por un lado, a De Gaulle no le quedó otro
remedio que permitir que las colonias africanas
se independizaran. Pensad que mantener colonias
es un negocio muy caro y Francia tenía bastante
con reconstruirse. Pero, como os podéis imaginar,
un gobierno con tantísimo ego no iba a permitir
que sus antiguas posesiones se marcharan del
todo. Así que Francia mantuvo su ejército
en todas sus antiguas colonias y, desde el
palacio del Elíseo, se dedicaron a “apoyar”
a todas las élites políticas que empezaban
a gobernar estos nuevos países africanos.
Por ejemplo, en el año 1964, el ejército
francés apoyó un golpe de estado en Gabón.
Desde entonces, Gabón estuvo gobernado por
la dictadura de OMAR BONGO durante más de
40 años ¿Y quién le suministraba todas
las armas? ¡Efectivamente! ¡Francia! A cambio,
Gabón sigue a rajatabla la política exterior
francesa y es su principal suministrador de
Uranio. Como sabéis, Francia es uno de los
países como más centrales nucleares del
mundo. Pues bien, el uranio que utilizan viene,
casi al 100%, de Gabón. Y, por supuesto,
a precio de amigo.
“Gabón sin Francia sería como un coche
sin conductor. Francia sin Gabón sería como
un coche sin combustible”
--Omar Bongo, presidente de Gabón durante
42 años.
Y lo mismo ocurre con otros países como Costa
de Marfil, cuya presidente también está
puesto, manu militari, por Francia, desde
el año 2011. El anterior salió del palacio
presidencial a cañonazos ¡Y adivinad quién
apretaba el gatillo! Efectivamente, los soldados
franceses. A cambio, Costa de Marfil es el
principal suministrador de café y cacao de
Francia.
Para que os hagáis una idea, la influencia
francesa en esta región es tan BRUTAL, que
hasta la moneda que utilizan está controlada
por Francia ¡Tal cual como lo oís!
Veréis, el llamado FRANCO CFA es la moneda
que se utiliza en 15 países de Africa Occidental
como puedan ser Mali, Burkina Faso o Costa
de Marfil… Pues bien, resulta que el Banco
Central que emite esta divisa está obligado
a guardar, al menos, la mitad de sus reservas
de divisa extranjera en el Tesoro Francés.
Y, desde su creación, el Franco CFA está
ligado a la divisa francesa: antes era el
Franco francés y ahora es el Euro. Es decir,
que cuando el Euro sube o baja de valor, el
Franco CFA replica los mismos movimientos.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque hay una letra
pequeña! Y esa letra es la economía productiva.
En otras palabras, Francia ha estado dirigiendo
la política de sus antiguas colonias durante
décadas. Pero estos países han seguido siendo
igual de pobres que cuando se independizaron.
Con la excepción de Costa de Marfil, los
países de la Francofonía Africana siguen
siendo economías subdesarrolladas, agrícolas
y prácticamente estancadas. Ninguna empresa
francesa se ha molestado en abrir fábricas
en África y el dinero que llegaba desde el
Elíseo, se invertía en armas o en extraer
recursos naturales. Nada más. A fin de cuentas…
¿Quién quiere hacer negocios en África?
Pues, creo que ya sabéis la respuesta.
CHINÁFRICA
Os lo hemos dicho mil veces aquí, en VisualPolitik,
hoy en día, China es el principal socio comercial
de África. Desde los años 90, China empezó
a crecer económicamente como si no existiera
mañana. Y cuando uno se pone a crecer, necesita
recursos. Hasta aquí, nada nuevo bajo el
Sol. Pero a diferencia de Francia o cualquier
otra potencia occidental, China se dio cuenta
en seguida de que África era algo más que
minas o yacimientos petrolíferos.
“Creo que África va a convertirse en la
nueva planta manufacturera del mundo. Y la
pobreza no será una maldición y millones
de personas en África escaparán de la pobreza”
La mujer a la que acabáis de escuchar se
llama Helen Hai y es una empresaria China.
Su compañía se llama HUAIJIAN y se dedica
a fabricar zapatos para grandes marcas. Si
tenéis algunos zapatos de marca GUESS o CALVIN
KLEIN, es muy probable que estén hechos por
esta empresa ¿Y a que no adivináis donde
tienen una de sus mayores fábricas? Pues
nada más y nada menos en Adiss Abeba, la
capital de Etiopía. Pensadlo bien. En los
años 90, China era la Meca de la mano de
obra barata. Todas las grandes empresas estadounidenses
o Europeas montaban sus fábricas en ciudades
como Shenzhen o GuanZhou.
Pero a medida que el país crece, los sueldos
también. Y para el año 2011, Helen Hai se
dio cuenta de que, si quería ahorrar costes
en salarios, tenía que buscar otro país.
Y ese país era Etiopía ¡Pero no sólo eso!
Helen Hai no viajaba sola. Tenía el apoyo
del Gobierno Chino, que se dirigió a las
élites políticas etíopes y les dijo “mirad,
chicos, si nos dejáis hacer las cosas a nuestra
manera, podemos cubrir el país de fábricas,
dinero y trabajos”. Y como solemos decir
por aquí… ¡Dicho y hecho!
El parquet industrial de Hawassa ya está
operativo y Etiopía quiere que se convierta
en un hub manufacturero
¡Pero no sólo hablamos de Etiopía! Podemos
encontrar fábricas chinas por muchos otros
países. TWYFORD es una empresa que fabrica
azulejos de cerámica y su principal planta
está en las afueras de Nairobi, en Kenia.
Y podemos encontrar nuevos parques industriales
en otros países como Ghana. Y, aunque las
empresas chinas estén apoyadas por el Gobierno,
hablamos en casi todos los casos de inversión
privada ¡Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
Que todas estas empresas se dedican a fabricar
cosas baratas para venderlas a los países
ricos ¿Verdad? ¡Pues nada de eso! Por ejemplo,
StarTimes es una empresa en TANZANIA con capital
Chino, que se dedica a dar televisión por
cable. Desde que llegaron al mercado, los
precios de la televisión por cable han bajado
en un 90%. Gracias a eso, más de 10 millones
de Africanos pueden disfrutar de un servicio
que antes era un lujo para unos pocos. Y lo
mismo ocurre con las telecomunicaciones. Empresas
como Huawei han inundado el mercado con teléfonos
móviles baratos. De hecho, hoy en día, los
Keniatas usan el móvil al mismo nivel que
los Europeos.
Y por supuesto, para conectar todos estos
centros industriales, el Gobierno Chino no
ha escatimado en dinero ¿Recordáis la Nueva
Ruta de la Seda? El llamado proyecto One Belt,
One Road que ha puesto en marcha Xi Jimping?
Pues también pasa por África. Y hablamos
de miles de kilómetros de ferrocarriles y
carreteras que han cambiado de arriba abajo
el paisaje de muchas zonas de África.
En otras palabras, que a diferencia de Francia,
China no se ha intentado colonizar África
sino que les ha convertido en socios comerciales.
Y gracias a eso, han conseguido ganar mucho
más dinero… y más influencia.
Los Institutos Confucio están criando generaciones
de hablantes de Mandarin con mentalidad pro
China en toda África
Y ahora os estaréis preguntando ¿Qué puede
hacer Francia al respecto? ¿Van a quedarse
de brazos cruzados mientras China les come
el mercado? Ahora lo vamos a ver.
INTERESES COMUNES
Creo que no os vais a sorprender si os digo
que buena parte de los países africanos no
son, precisamente, paraísos de seguridad
jurídica y respeto por la ley. En muchos
casos, hablamos de dictaduras. En otros, estados
fallidos que a duras penas pueden contener
las peleas de distintas tribus.
Eso significa que, montar una fábrica en
un país como Gabón es bastante más complicado
que en Estados Unidos, por poner un ejemplo.
No basta con comprar unos terrenos y conseguir
un permiso: hay que tener contactos en el
Gobierno. Es decir, que la diplomacia en estos
casos, juega un papel fundamental. ¿Recordáis
que os había dicho que Francia controla con
mano de hierro a los gobiernos de sus antiguas
colonias? Pues os podéis imaginar el resto
de la historia.
“Las empresas franceses tienen que estar
a la ofensiva y luchar contra la influencia
de la rival China en los, cada vez más competitivos,
mercados de África. Estan son las palabras
del ministro de finanzas francés, Pierre
Moscovici”
Como os podéis imaginar, si Francia no quiere
que China invierta en sus excolonias, tiene
herramientas suficientes para evitarlo. Y
por eso, el dinero Chino apenas ha llegado
a estos países ¡Por supuesto que Beijin
ha pagado algunos proyectos en países como
Costa de Marfil o Gabón! Pero poca cosa comparado
con Etiopía o Kenia.
Sin embargo, las cosas podrían empezar a
cambiar. El nuevo presidente de Francia, Emmanual
Macron, ha prometido dar un giro de 180º
en lo que se refiere a África. Y parece que
ya ha pasado a la acción.
Macron resucita su asociación con China en
África
Tal cual dijo Macrón en la rueda de prensa,
“China tiene el dinero y nosotros el conocimiento
de la región”. En otras palabras, que Francia
estaría dispuesta a permitir que los políticos
africanos a los que controlan acepten la inversión
china. Ahora bien, a cambio, quieren un trozo
del pastel. Por supuesto, esta noticia es
de enero de 2018 y todavía queda mucho para
ver cómo llegará a ponerse en práctica
este acuerdo.
Así que ahora la pregunta es ¿Creéis que
Francia cambiará su política con África
y empezará a tratar a sus antiguas colonias
como socios comerciales? ¿O se quedará todo
en buenas palabras? ¿Pensáis que esto puede
ser un nuevo empujón para que África salga
de la pobreza antes, incluso, de lo que nos
imaginamos? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si queréis saber cómo África
está dejando atrás la pobreza, haced click
en este otro vídeo.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos videos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE, compartidlo con
vuestros amigos, y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!